the best shape has been in probably in
20 years right now you know that's
Britney Spears talking about her bod she
called in to Ryan Seacrest kiss a fan
morning radio show on Friday and while
she really is in the best shape ever she
joked that she may have gotten a little
help from technology when Ryan brought
up the fierce artwork for her song make
me you are like ripped there's so much
they can do with computers to make
people look a certain way I took what I
like to take a picture it's like you
know I might as well eat six pieces of
tea set because if you can't you can fix
it it's really kind of cool to be able
to do that but let's be honest the mom
of two doesn't need much editing she
often flaunts her physique on Instagram
Britney also teased her upcoming album
glory suffer release later this month
it's really different it doesn't what I
think is just probably the most hip hop
album there are like two or three songs
that go in the direction of more urban
that I've wanted to do for a long time
down